joining us right off the very top of our
second hour but first on NBCSN is the
head coach of the Dallas Mavericks and
has been so since 2008 he's been a part
party he's been with the Americas
organization for quite some time um he
is Rick Carlisle
how are you coach I'm well rich how are
you I'm doing better for talking to you
sir I guess let's talk about what's
going on with your team first and
foremost and what's going on in the real
world Rick what have you talked to your
your your players and team about and
obviously the team owner Rick Mark Cuban
has been very vocal about what's been
going on outside the doors of your
organization what have you been talking
about with your players whenever you
have the opportunity to be with them
Rick well you're referring to the unrest
the societal unrest yes sir the racial
injustice
George Floyd and a lot of other
situations and it's a very important
question a couple of weeks ago when the
George Floyd incident happened we we got
our entire 30 head coaches together
within about a six hour period there was
just a real feeling of anger and you
know just the need to get together and
talk about what was going on in the
world within the world to to try to use
the platform that we have to try to do
something to make it better and so
within six hours we get together a
thirty NBA head coach zoom call and form
the committee which is called the NBC a
committee on racial injustice and reform
and led by Lloyd Pierce head coach of
the Atlanta Hawks committee consists of
some of our really outspoken people on
this topic over the years Gregg Popovich
Steve Kerr JB Bickerstaff Stan Van Gundy
David finsdale Bret Braun Doc Rivers and
Quin Snyder
and as president of the Coaches
Association I'm not on the committee
Obama but I'm on all the calls we've had
four calls with the committee and what
we're gonna do is mobilize as a head
coaching group we're going to partner
with a local organization or two in our
local markets learn the lay of the land
with respect to all of these different
problems that we're having today and
then likely partner with the Obama
foundation is kind of a big umbrella and
then you know we're planning to be in
this fight for for the long haul we're
interested in making a difference we're
interested in educating people on racial
injustice and because these things have
been going going for decades stacked on
centuries and it's just it just got to a
point where you know if there as I said
there was a mobilization of the group
and I've never seen the group so
determined so we're excited to get
started we know it's a a very long
battle but we've got the stomach for it
and you know we're into it Wow so you
all 30 head coaches in the National
Basketball Association just got together
on a zoom and just started hashing it
out is that what you're saying you're
all got together there was a there was a
white Pierce the as I mentioned coach
Atlanta quail hogs right you know you
know asked for the floor and he had just
a very strong speech to the group about
his sentiments you know he's an Africa
African American coach who grew up
living and seeing all these and justices
and you know it's been going on for
decades and centuries as I mentioned and
George Floyd just it just put everybody
over the top which which is saying a lot
and so personally I'm partnering with a
group in Dallas called
mothers against police brutality which
is a
phenomenal group of people that are a
grassroots organization in Dallas only
and we've got a meeting scheduled with
the mayor of Dallas tomorrow afternoon
and you know we plan to to start start
the conversation and and and and partner
with as many people as we can that
didn't have real influence in all of our
cities to to try to effect change and
you were the head coach when Steven
Jackson was with the Pacers Rick so and
you know clearly obviously um that
George Floyd was a close personal friend
of Stephens who and he has been just
remarkable and personalizing and and
being there for the family as well as
bringing home to anyone who may need to
know about George Floyd that here was a
real man a real person who had an
officer put put his knee on on his neck
and kill him in the streets of
Minneapolis I mean he was it Stephens
been remarkable for that image frozen in
time will be one that lives on in
perpetuity it's got to be a major
reminder that you know this this these
things have got to stop Steven Jackson
is not only was a tremendous basketball
player but he's a passionate guy very
animated person and a guy with a great
heart I was with him for multiple years
and he he had a couple of really great
years with Indiana as a player and you
know this has been it's been tragic to
see this happen and I'd have to see his
reaction to it although he's handled it
with with an amazing amount of of grace
and fortitude
Rick Carlisle Dallas Mavericks head
coach here on the Rich Eisen show and
then oh yeah there's a pandemic so
what's going on with with that how are
you preparing with now a schedule and a
location and a date certain by which the
league plans to open are you are you are
you ready to roll
right now Rick how about that is this
question well there's no we're
collecting information I think every
team has one person or another that's on
some kind of committee relative to this
things are becoming clearer and clearer
you know there's been a you know there's
been an understandable hesitation to
throw hard dates out there you know
early on in this process because there's
so many unknowns but you know generally
you know players will be back in market
you know by the 21st of June you know
test testing will start in local local
markets you know there will be a
training camp in your local market for
some period of time and then there will
be a staggered you know movement of
teams to tour land on us that's the
basics that that I know about that I
know that there is an asterisk really
next next to everything in terms of the
level of fluidity that we're dealing
with here so when we're excited to get
back playing you know I know I know our
players are excited I think every
facility has been open now for a while
for individual workouts you know there's
a great amount of care and detail in
keeping the facilities clean you know in
between workouts you know after people
leave at the end of the day etc and you
know we're just we're all gonna have to
have a laser a laser-like focus you know
on everything that we're doing and then
outside like let's let's all hope we get
past the point where the kovat 19 is at
the forefront and that the protocols and
the health and safety measures can allow
everybody to just focus on the
competition you being the seven seed
going in what's your thoughts on the
fact that the schedule in the West you
got eight games that you're gonna have
to play and it may not be very balanced
schedule compared to people that have
this
same number as wins as you right now and
and compared to the East that it's a
simple one because there's just nine
teams and they everyone will play each
other once what do you think of that
well yeah my feeling is that they had to
come up with something that made sense
and what makes sense isn't necessarily
going to have great symmetry in this
situation you know I my understanding is
that we will likely be playing our next
eight games on the schedule which does
make sense and most of those games were
were against teams that are going to be
playing so in in the in Orlando so
mmm-hmm hey we got to keep our eye on
the ball we got a you know take care of
our own business I'd not get too much
into analysis of other people's
situations try to do everything possible
to get our players in the best possible
condition in the right way we've never
had a situation where we come off of a
three month layoff quite like this
normally when you come off the summer
you know players will report around
voluntarily report around Labor Day and
then you'll have a three week period it
kind of fades everybody in you know with
voluntary workouts pickup games and so
forth along with work with your strength
coaches this hasn't this hasn't been
that level of normalcy and so we're
dealing with a different you know a far
different set of circumstances but we
have a lot of smart people in this
league we have a lot of smart people on
all these teams and you know we'll work
through it meticulously and in terms of
your personal team and issues that might
be you know obviously I think
everybody's got players who might be in
Europe I mean to your best our sheltered
in place there how much contact do you
have with with Luca throughout this
entire process in porzingis coach yeah
we got contact with them they've been on
zoom' calls you know you know that all
that will be will be taken care of in
terms of them being back here at the
right time and
and we'll proceed from there but it's in
you know this just three month period
and it really it's amazing to me that
it's gone by as quickly as it has I mean
the first week or two seemed to drag and
then I somehow or other it's all gone by
pretty fast and you know in another two
weeks you know we'll be in the midst of
testing and then getting ready for for
you know our local training camp
situations to begin so we're excited but
but cautiousness as well and there will
continue to be a lot of communication
throughout our league you know on best
practices as we get back into you know
these workouts with our players etc and
you know safety is is the number-one
concern
straight across the board a couple more
questions for you Rick Carlisle Dallas
Mavericks head coach any conversation
being had with the coaches in your zoom
or with the players in terms of any
protest that is going to be expected to
be had prior to any games during any
workouts prior to any games based on
what is going on in the real world I
know there's been a conversation about
what the NFL may do but the NBA is gonna
be first up if we're knocking on wood
everything goes according to plan kovat
wise any conversation on that front of
what you're hearing Rick all right now
that the coaches are focused on you know
as I mentioned an action plan involving
all 30 markets to to really dive into
something that's going to be individual
in nature because everybody's mark it's
going to be a little different but we're
all going to be under the same umbrella
and we're gonna all have to a great
degree similar messaging and so you know
when you're talking about progress you
know a peaceful protest can be part of
that but but so far our conversations
have really been about you know how
we're going to be able to proceed and
progress you know when when there were
situations involving possible protests
in the last several years what I can
tell you is that you
with our organization with the Mavericks
Mark Cuban and myself in talking to our
players said hey listen guys you know
this is a free country you guys are free
to do whatever you wish you're free to
express yourselves however you wish and
but we we urge you to talk about what
you're going to do and and and let us
know if you're going to do something
just so we're aware and we never had any
any protesting things happen with our
team and you know there were some teams
that that still do they still lock arms
during the net the national anthem as a
show of togetherness and things like
that
you know I I don't know what's going to
what if anything is going to happen but
you know we love the fact that the
conversation conversation has opened up
and it's going it's going to be animated
and but we believe it's going to be
ongoing last one for you Rick I would be
remiss if I did not point out they you
were an assistant on that pasters team
that was so prominently featured in the
final couple episodes of the last dance
the Jordan documentary on ESPN you are a
Larry Bird assistant you were also
player on the Knicks teams as Jordan was
ascending towards his six championships
did you learn anything from that last
dance
Rick watch as I said you did I mean you
know learning I thought I thought the
entire documentary was extremely well
done you know that kind of access and
those kinds of you know being able to
see in locker rooms he practices see
inside hotel rooms and you know and and
all the different things that were going
on it was laid out in such a way that
you know you could really get a feel for
the chronology of it as well as the
impact of all those things you know I
think you know look looking at that at
that entire series you know it's just it
puts you know
us me more in awe of Phil Jackson and
what he accomplished you know and very
unusual and unusually challenging
situations and how he was you know I'm
constantly able to finish with all these
teams and win and win championships and
we had him on a Coaches Association
membership widezoom Paul but this past
Monday and we had a one of our
development sessions and we had over 150
of our to 190 coaches on and Phil was on
a zoom call and he was taking questions
from our membership you know on just on
various different things and so you know
I thought it was great I love the focus
of the last dance on you know when you
play during that period of time the
number one focus you know with with the
great players was Championships how many
rings you know how many rings you got
between Michael and Larry after that
game seven Rick we caught that one
reason what they caught between the two
you know when I was playing with Burt
was playing when Jordan was playing the
magic was playing you know you know you
know putting myself in with those guys
you know in this cover in this sentence
you know talking about when we were
playing me magic Larry and I'm not be
too presumptuous here but I just
remember that you know and Isiah Thomas
and and Dumars and you know all those
guys it was all about it was all about
the big prize and I love the fact that
that documentary really focused on the
obsession with Championships and I think
it's a great message for today's players
because look back in those days nobody
even had cell phones and I mean let
alone social media
all the different kinds of distractions
and things going on today and there's a
lot more money flying around today etc
you know the the focus and the emphasis
on winning titles was just that was that
was a beautiful thing for me to say I've
been fortunate to be on two championship
teams in the NBA in one playing and one
coaching I know and I know how hard it
is and and that feeling you get you know
when when you get when you get to the
end and you've and you've accomplished
it I mean it's a it's a it's a magical
magical feeling that can never be
duplicated Rick thanks for the call
really appreciate it enjoyed our
conversation good luck with you as you
get to Disney World and and hopefully
everybody is safe and healthy and we I
can't wait to watch the competition
thank you for the call
all right that's Rick Carlisle the head
coach of the Dallas Mavericks
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here